how are the tests designed iq test
design how do they work maybe some
examples for people who are not aware
what
what makes a good iq test question that
sneaks up on this on this g factor
measure well your question is
interesting because you want me to give
examples of items that make good items
and what makes a good item is not so
much its content
but its empirical relationship to the
total score that
turns out to be valid by other means
yeah so for example
let me give you an odd example from
personality testing nice
so there's a personality test called the
minnesota multiphasic personality
inventory mmpi been around for decades
i've heard about this test recently
because of the johnny depp and uh amber
heard trial i don't know if you've been
paying attention to that but they have
not been paying attention they had
psychologists on the st on the stand and
they were talking apparently those
psychologists did uh
again i'm learning so much from this
trial they they have uh they did
different at the battery of tests
to uh diagnose personality disorders
apparently there's that
systematic way of doing so and the
minnesota one is
one of the ones that there's the most
science on there's a lot of great papers
which were all
continuously cited on the stand which is
fascinating to watch sorry a little bit
of attention okay i mean this is
interesting because you're right it's
been around for decades there are a lot
of scientific research on the
psychometric properties
of the test
including what it predicts
with respect to
different categories of personality
disorder
but what i want to mention is the
content of the items on that test
all of the items
are essentially
true false items
true or false i prefer a shower to a
bath
true or false i think lincoln was a
better president than washington
now what have all these what does that
have to do
and the point is the content of these
items nobody knows why
these items in aggregate predict
anything
but empirically they do
it's a technique of of choosing items
for a test
that is called dust bowl empiricism
that the content doesn't matter but
there it for some reason when you get a
criterion group of people with this
disorder and you compare them to people
without that disorder these are the
items that distinguish
irrespective of content it's a hard
concept to grasp well uh first of all
it's fascinating
but
uh from uh because i
i i consider myself part psychologist
uh because i love human robot
interaction and that's a problem half of
that problem
is a psychology problem because there's
a human
um so designing these tests to get at
the questions
is the fascinating part like how do you
get
to uh like what does dust bowl
empiricism refer to does it
refer to the final result
yeah so it's the test this dust bowl uh
empiricism but how do you arrive at the
battery of questions i presume
uh one of the things now again i'm going
to the excellent testimony in that trial
uh the explanation also the they explain
the tests
uh that a bunch of the questions are
kind of
make you
forget that you're taking a test
like
it makes it very difficult for you to
somehow figure out what what uh
you're supposed to answer yes it's
called social desirability but we're
getting a little far afield because i
only wanted to give that example of dust
bowl empiricism
when we talk about the items on an iq
test
many of those
items in the dust bowl and piercing
method have no face validity in other
words they don't look like they measure
anything
yes
whereas most intelligence tests the
items actually look like they're
measuring some mental ability so here's
here's one so you were bringing that up
as an example as what it is not yes got
it okay
so i don't want to go too far afield on
it well too far afield is actually one
of the names of this podcast so uh
i should mention that far afield far
field uh yeah so anyway sorry so so they
feel the questions look like they they
pass the face validity test and some
more than others and so for example let
me give you a couple of things here
if i
one of the subtests on a standard iq
test is
general information
let me just think a little bit because i
don't want to give you the actual item
but if i said how far is it
between
washington dc and miami florida
within 500 miles plus or minus
well you know it's not a fact most
people memorize
but you can you know something about
geography you say well i flew there once
i know planes fly for 500 miles you know
you can get you can kind of make an
estimate
but it's also seems like it would be
very cultural
um you know
so there's that kind of
general information then there's
vocabulary tests what does
uh
regatta mean
and i choose that word because that word
was removed from the iq test because
people complained that disadvantaged
people would not know that word
just from their everyday
life
okay
here's another example from a different
kind of subtest on what's regatta by the
way a regatta is a um i think i'm like
advantageous a sailing competition a
competition with boats
not necessarily sailing but the
competition will close
yep yep okay i'm proudly disadvantaged
in that way okay excellent so that was
removed okay what you were saying okay
so now here's a here's another subtest
i'm going to repeat a string of numbers
and when i'm done i want you to repeat
them back to me
ready
okay 7
4
2
eight
one
six
that's way too many seven four two eight
one six okay you get the idea now the
actual test starts with
a smaller number
you know like two numbers and then it is
people get it right you keep going
adding to the string of numbers until
they can't do it anymore
okay but now try this
i'm gonna reap i'm gonna say some
numbers and when i'm done i want you to
repeat them to me backwards
i quit
okay
now
so i gave you some examples of the kind
of items on an iq test general
information
um i
can't even remember all general
information vocabulary
digit span
forward and digit span
backward
well you said i can't even remember that
that's a good question for me
uh what does memory have to do with
jesus well
let's hold that okay all right so let's
let's let's just talk about these
examples now
some of those
items
seem very cultural
and
others seem less cultural
which ones do you think
scores on which subtest are most highly
correlated with the g factor
well the two advances less cultural
well
it turns out vocabulary is highly
correlated
and it turns out that digitspan
backwards
is highly correlated
how do you figure now you have
decades of research to answer the
question how do you figure
right so no now there's like good
research that gives you intuition about
what kind of questions get at it just
like uh
um
there's something
i've done
i've actually used for research to send
me a autonomous vehicle like whether
humans are paying attention there's a
body of literature that does like end
back tests for example we have to
um
put workload on the brain to do recall
memory recall and that helps you kind of
put some work onto the brain while the
person is doing some other tasks and
this does some interesting research with
that
uh but that's loading the memory so
there's like research around
stably
what that means about the human mind and
here you're saying recall backwards
is a good predictor the transformation
yeah so you have to so you have to do
some
some like you have to load that into
your brain and not just remember it but
do something with it right here's
another example of a different kind of
test called the hick paradigm and it's
not verbal at all
it's a little box
and there are series of lights
arranged in a semi-circle
at the top of the box
and then there's a home button that you
press
and when one of the lights goes on
there's a button next to each of those
lights
you take your finger off the home button
and you just press
the button next to the light that goes
on
and so it's a very simple reaction time
light goes on as quick as you can you
press the button
and you get a reaction time from the
moment you lift your finger off the
button
when you press
the button with where the light is
that reaction time
doesn't really correlate with iq very
much
but if you change
the instructions
and you say
three lights are going to come on
simultaneously
i want you to press the button next to
the light that's furthest from the other
two
so maybe lights one and two go on and
and light six goes on simultaneously you
take your finger off and you would press
the button by light six
that's
that reaction time to a more complex
task
it's not really hard
almost everybody gets it all right but
the your reaction time to that
is highly correlated with the g factor
this is fascinating so reaction time so
there's a temporal
aspect to this so it's what what role
crossing it's the speed of processing is
this also true for ones that take longer
like 5 10 30 seconds
is time part of the measure with
something yes yes and that is why some
of the best iq tests
have a time limit
because if you have no time limit
people can do better yeah but it doesn't
it doesn't distinguish among people
that well
so that
adding the time element is important so
speed of information processing
turn and reaction time is a measure of
speed of information processing turns
out to be related to the g factor
you